افادت وزاره الصحه الفلسطينيه في قطاع غزه
بسقوط الشاهدين واصابه اثنين في قصف
اسرائيلي استهدف سياره شرق خان يونس وقالت
مصادر فلسطينيه ان الاستهداف الاسرائيليه
تسبب في سقوط عدد من الاصابات شرقيه خان
يونس
من جهته قال الجيش الاسرائيلي ان طائره
تابعه لسلاح الجو الاسرائيلي استهدفت عصر
اليوم مجموعه من وحده الصواريخ المضاده
للدروع تابعه لحركه الجهاد الاسلامي هذا
هو اوضح ان المجموعه كانت تستقل سياره في
طريقها الى موقع الرمي في مدينه خان يونس
جنوبيه قطاعي غزه
جاء ذلك بعد ساعات من الغارات التي شنتها
اسرائيل على القطاع وادت الى استشهاد 13
بينهم اربعه اطفال وخمس نساء واصابه عشرين
اخرين ومن بين الشهداء ثلاثه من قاده
سرايا القدس هم جهاد الغنام ابي نسر
المجلس العسكري لسرايا القدس وخليل
البهتيني عضو المجلس العسكري وقائد
المنطقه الشماليه في قطاع غزه وطارق عز
الدين احد قاده العمل العسكري لسرايا
القدس في الضفه الغربيه فيما يسود ترقب
بشان طبيعه الرد الفلسطيني المتوقع